shady this is the house targeted by US
helicopters they approach the site at
midnight and sealed the area off before
they stormed it one person was taken
away others were killed in a car passing
through was destroyed the US forces also
handed over three children to one of the
neighbors and requested they take them
far away and then come back after the
operation was completed seven dead
bodies have been recovered so far this
home was then bombed by us helicopters
accompanied by a recon plane in a war
plane this house is said to have
belonged to Abu Muhammad Al Houla P we
were told by an eyewitness he bought the
house two years ago the owner of this
house was not the target the target was
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi as you can see the
house is totally destroyed leveled to
the ground the operation lasted four
hours okay let's take another live
update on this developing story Osama
Bin Gervais joins us now from Barry
Hanley on the turkey-syria border Osama
what do we make of the location of this
compound what six seven kilometers from
the Turkish border absolutely and we're
just a few kilometers away from that
border ourselves on the Turkish side of
the turkey-syria border this is the
location where Baghdadi's last few days
were spent president Trump going into
details of how according to him the
place was scoped for a few days before
they took this action and and then
providing us context into this is a
location where he thought that abu bakr
al baghdadi could rebuild ISIL from it
is an area where there's a lost of
disenfranchisement this is an area which
is under the control of Al qaeda-linked
has hired Terry Raja which was formerly
known as Innes refer as another affront
so it is an area where a bakr al
baghdadi was there we don't know for how
long but some intelligence reports have
suggested that he had been on the move
since 2014 the first time we saw him in
Mosul making that grand appearance
declaring the Islamic State of Iraq and
the Levant which was then taken out by a
60 plus member Alliance what we also
know about this is is the the kind of
cooperation that went into this and it
was kind of very unprecedented the way
the US president described and the order
in which he thanked the people or
foremost on that list was Russia dance
then Iraq then Turkey and then Kurdish
fighters the Curtis head had been saying
that they had been involved for about
five months but the president US
president saying that they had given
some information which was useful but
largely this operation was carried out
according to US intelligence reports
also what is interesting in the last
couple of minutes we've heard from the
Russian Foreign Ministry shrugging
almost shrugging off this death as
saying that one more death of Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi does not have real
implication about the strategic security
in Syria it goes to show that on the
ground who is really in charge in
calling the shots the president Trump
repeatedly thanking the Russians for
allowing him and his forces to pass over
areas that they control thanking Turkey
and the Turks have also said that they
have they were actually notified before
this operation took place so it was a
complicated operation it looks like
America has got its public enemy number
one but what it means for ISIL and the
conditions which created ISIL are is a
question that will remain in this region
beyond the death of Abu Bakr al Baghdadi
just to be clear Osama this compound is
it inside or outside the safe area that
mr. Erdogan wants to set up it is
outside of the safe zone that president
Ardoin wants to set up on the
turkey-syria border this is an area
which was controlled by another
agreement between Turkey and Russia
under a deconfliction zone but we know
that large parts of the idli province
are under the control of Al qaeda-linked
Hyatt ariram
although Turkey says that it has helped
other fighters take administrative
responsibility but on the ground the
situation is that they are very strong
and they have a very powerful prevalent
presence even the videos that you saw of
the aftermath of the compound hiya Terry
Russian fighters came there they
evacuated the area they cordoned off the
whole place and told journalists to
leave so it is an area which is close to
the Turkish border which is again raised
many questions about why abu bakr al
baghdadi was there and also whether he
was trying to flee and save his family